I chose this life Sunday it's going to  get me killed  but not today  [Music]  lorraine bracco thanks for it in the  intelligence collection and hand-to-hand  combat cage in Gascoigne was killed last  night did you know him enough to say  that he had an atomic bomb of  information and find out who's hunting  our operatives and trust no one  [Music]  be honest  David because your content welcome to  Berlin hunting don't issue  I've got a shoe yeah  [Music]  building a from the moment makes you  touch the ground  she's never passed the plan as far as  mine I've lost the target do you know  what this woman who's been following me  he look like in a favor  [Music]  so you made contact with the French  opera obviously  [Music]  the clock is ticking and everyone you  you're close to ends up dead  don't get near someone from the inside  now let's assume the ends one way  [Music]  Oh  and  wouldn't I can we away  my god I think I love you that's too bad  [Music]  you  you